traveling from constituency two
constituencies so much talk is about new
forces insurgent parties you get the
Greaves the SNP but don't lose sight of
the central battleground that is as ever
labor against conservative arriving in
Ipswich a classic labour Tory marginal I
hadn't anticipated the only campaigning
in the main square might be on behalf of
a brand of cheese they're a tough crowd
if enthusiasm for a free cheese sandwich
was not overwhelming enthusiasm for the
general election was in still shorter
supply they break the promises they
don't they never do what they say
they're going to do it's the fact that
they're all sound the same thing but
nothing nothing ever comes from it
they're basically all the same it
doesn't really matter to me what party
comes in what doesn't so I think invoked
possibly labor that's not very
enthusiastic netball know because I've
said they're all as bad as each other
aren't they the mayor of Essos really I
mean they say one thing and must place
it comes down to the x or general
election after election do they do this
do it actually sick boy what they say
you sound skeptical dear oh dear and
that's the backdrop against which the
two main parties are scrapping away the
Tories hold the seat by a couple of
thousand most recent polling suggests
labor should reclaim it but this is in
the balance all right perceptive the
economy i think is improving I've always
voted conservative yeah I think they've
been doing a good job and there's no
reason for me to to change I think it's
better the devil you know at least we
know that David Cameron's bring the
country up whereas labored brought the
country down there weren't too many
labour supporters around this particular
afternoon the one I did find was worth
his weight in gold liba
of course I feel they're just amazing
you say amazing yeah what's so amazing
what's it always just so much to be
honest if I start talking about it I'm
not going to stop well you need to talk
to more other people around here because
not that many people here think they're
amazing well really in the bus so many
people don't think that amazing
obviously they haven't looked at what
the things they've done but if they're
really going to fees have done and
they'll be even ashamed to say that
amazing what a breath of fresh air I
told this gentleman ed miliband could do
with an army of supporters like him
instead whether it's labor all the
Tories they must confront a generally
grumpy and begrudging electorate in
Ipswich and elsewhere if they're to eke
out a majority